Hello. Hello. Hello.
Hey. How's it going? Hey. How?
Alright. How are you both today?
Doing pretty good. I'm fine. Excited to be
joining.
This I guess this is my sort of
second time on the stream. I don't know
if the first one counts. It wasn't it
wasn't official. It was impromptu.
So
but we kinda The best streams, though. Right?
The impromptu ones where you have no idea
what's going on or not. Mean Right. This
is my twentieth time, and I still have
no idea how to introduce this stream other
than I'll be like,
hi.
Like
eventually, I'll come up with some sort of
script. But for now, when you know, it's
working alright.
Yeah. Well, wasn't it. You've been getting these
streams out super fast. When did you start
doing this this specific show? Because I've I've
been watching, and it's like it's almost, like,
daily at this point. Whereas I think I've
been doing streams for about a year now,
and I'm at, like, 21 shows. So, like,
your pace is
infinitely faster than mine.
Yeah. I'm averaging three a week right now.
Wow. Which is quite a lot. And they're,
you know
but, I mean, as you two have just
found out today, there's, like, zero prep. I
I pretty much just find people that are
doing cool shit and, like, say, hey. Do
you wanna come and join me? And then
just,
you know, free flow, kinda go through the
technology and see what works and what doesn't.
Like, it's not like there's a whole lot
of prep going into this that's taking loads
of time.
Fair enough. Not that I should be broadcasting
to other people that are gonna tune in
and watch. This is really polished, we all
know exactly what we're doing. We rehearsed for
weeks.
Okay.
So today's mission
is we're we're gonna talk about some Kubernetes
cool stuff.
I believe and you can correct me if
I'm wrong here. But this is mostly possible
since Kubernetes one nineteen, which came out last
week. Is that correct?
Oh, we are backwards compatible.
So we are always trying to pull up
bring up some enhancement to the community which
works on previous versions of Kubernetes too.
So yeah.
But the initial
reason for our work was that we found
out during the graduation of seccomp to GA
in 01/19 that, hey. There are so many
enhancements which could probably go with that feature,
but it probably would be better to put
them out of three.
And now we have our little community around
it, and we are getting more and more
contributors to the project. And, yeah, we're pretty
happy that we can
provide some valuable content to the community in
that way.
Yeah. I'm I'm really excited to play with
us today, actually. Mhmm. It's one of those
things that I know you know, security is
a big deal, especially
when we're talking about cloud computing and Kubernetes
and especially if you've got public facing traffic
of any kind. So
we're just in attack factors and all that
other stuff. I'm not gonna pretend I know
about security, but I know a few words
I can drop in, like, attack vector.
And second operator, which is a project that
YouTube have been involved in, I think, is
a big component of that. So do you
wanna just
take a minute to describe what this project
is and and how it works and helps
people be securing the next one? Dan, do
you wanna take it? Sure. Yeah. I can
I can jump in on that? So as
Sasha said,
set comp has existed in Kubernetes for for
quite a while and and and the Linux
kernel as well. So, basically, set comp is
just, you know, when you have a process
running in user space,
it typically, to do anything meaningful, needs to
access some of the functionality
in kernel space. And to do that, it
uses syscalls. Right? So it says, hi, kernel.
Like, you have more privilege than me. Please
go do this task for me.
And so you can imagine since it has
to communicate in this language,
you could pretty easily put in a layer
they there to filter what calls are going
through to the kernel.
And that's a pretty effective way to, you
know, establish security boundaries on things because the
the functionality of different syscalls is pretty well
defined,
though there are a lot of them, which
we'll probably find out later on in the
stream.
But being able to restrict what syscalls a
process can accomplish
is is really effective. And especially when you
bring in containerization,
you can apply profiles to that.
It can get a lot more effective. So
anyway, you've been able to do this for
quite a while with annotations
on pods and containers
in in Kubernetes,
and you can also do that on on
pod security policies to enforce these sorts of
things. Most container runtimes, which for folks who
aren't as familiar with Kubernetes,
Kubernetes is an orchestration
orchestration layer that sits on top of a
container runtime. Right? So you could swap out
the underlying container runtime,
which we we may talk about a little
bit. But most of them ship with kind
of a default
set comp profile, which is like, this is,
you know, the bare minimum security you could
have here. It's like, you it's not gonna
do anything too atrocious.
But most people, you won't even see enabling
that, right, because
it is an annotation you have to add.
So it's kind of like unstructured data. It's
not a formal field if you look at
the API spec for a pod.
So, yeah, you don't see it used a
lot in Kubernetes even though it's been around
for quite a while.
And as Sasha mentioned,
as part of the one dot '19 release,
Sasha and I and Paulo Gomez,
who,
led a big part of this as well,
graduated set comp to GA. So essentially, what
that means and this sounds kind of simple,
but if you're familiar with kind of how
API changes work in Kubernetes, you'll know it's
it's not super simple.
We basically just took those annotations and made
them a formal part of the security context.
So that has a number of benefits. One
of the biggest I see is that it's
just, you know, a a field that's there
in the API spec, right, that you can
set as part of your security context. It's
in the documentation as such, and it's less
of kind of like an afterthought.
So anyway,
basically, same functionality
for the most part, but just moving that
to the actual formal pod spec. And as
Sacha mentioned, as part of that,
we wanted to enable you to make it
easier to use that comp. So once again,
for folks who aren't as familiar with Kubernetes,
typically, there are a number of nodes running.
So each of those nodes have a container
runtime on them. The Kubernetes scheduler is gonna
go and take your pods, are made up
of containers, put those on the nodes, which
are gonna run those with the container runtime
that they're interfacing with.
So you can imagine
if the if set comp is something that's
at the kernel layer,
that is on a per node basis. Right?
So you can't just say, I I'd like
the set comp profile to be used and
assume that it's present on all nodes.
Right now, you have to actually go in
and, you know, when you're setting up your
machine or SSH ing into your machine or
something like that, you have to go and
actually put them in a directory that's specified
with the kubelet flag
and make sure those are present on all
of your nodes.
So it's it's very for something that you
can configure on a pod spec, it's very
divorced from the actual running of a workload.
Right? It's very much a a cluster administrator
activity,
which, you know, has has some pros and
cons. Right? Typically, the cluster administrator is gonna
be knowledgeable of those things and can do
it. But if you want to, you know,
constantly be changing the seccomp profiles that are
available and creating new ones for for different
processes you're running in in a different container,
then that's kind of a pain. Right? So
let's say I'm I'm running a a workload
and I'm just a developer in my organization.
I I need to create my pod.
You know, I don't want to have to
email my my cluster administrator and say, hey.
Will you go make sure there's a seccomp
profile on this node? And then I'm gonna
put, you know, like, specific node taints on
here to make sure the pod gets scheduled
there and do all that. Like, it it's
it's mixing of responsibility there, it's kind of,
like, moving away from this whole pattern that
Kubernetes is trying to,
enforce.
So what we'd like to do is take
the, set comp functionality and make it available
more at that developer level,
or just make it easier for cluster administrators
to to use and and create pod security
policies.
So,
anyway, the set comp operator is kind of
typical to Kubernetes operators. It it watches,
an API type. Right now, we're just using
config map, so there's no new API type
that's added.
And that config map has data in it,
is basically just set comp profiles. And it'll
go and it runs as a daemon set.
So this operator is running on every node,
and it actually goes and puts those in
the correct directory,
which means that you can then say on
your pod,
you know, use this set comp profile with
this name, which I know exists because I
can queue control, get my config maps that
are set comp profiles
and and know which ones are available to
me, and then apply them to my workloads.
And we can run through through doing all
of this, but that's kind of the main
idea. We'd like to make it really easy
to use this really valuable functionality.
Okay. There is a whole lot of information
there. So I what I'm gonna do is
make sure that I have understood it correctly,
and I'm gonna try and scrape it back
to you now. Sounds
good.
So second. Right?
Let's remove Kubernetes and containers for now. It's
a Linux kernel primitive
that allows me to define the syscalls that
any binary running on that machine are allowed
to execute.
Right?
Exactly.
The second profile is something that I have
to craft myself, and I put in a
directory that Linux kernel expects it to live
in.
And
so how do you connect the profile to
the binary? Like, it's beside Kubernetes. Like, if
I was just doing this on a Linux
machine, how would that work?
Yeah. I mean,
it's more or less so the profile profiles
itself are not not written in JSON. So
they are just for example, you can use
libseccom, which is a c library,
and then you can use it to interface
with the seccom BPF filter filter, and then
you can generate or build the filter. For
example, you allow only a subset of this
calls for your current currently running architecture.
And then you have to call something like
filter load, and then the filter gets loaded
into the kernel and
attached to a process. And,
yeah, that's it. So it's it has to
be attached to a running process.
Oh, okay.
Okay. So that that was a bit of
a disconnect for me then.
So I have a running process. I attached
the profile to it, and that process is
then secure. If that exits and is rerun
by someone else, I would have to reattach
the profile?
No. I don't I think the profile is
gone if the process exits. But I think,
originally,
seccomp had no support,
so there was no support for those data
structure where you can specify differences calls.
In the first place, it was just something
like, okay. We want to use seccomp or
we don't want to use it. And if
we enable seccomp for a process, then the
process can't do new SYS calls. So that's
that was the main intention, but that that
wasn't flexible enough.
And then they decided to go for BPF.
It's not eBPF, so it's not this extended
BPF
filtering,
but it's just a plain BPF.
So there's more or less something like a
you can imagine it something like a lightweight
common module which gets which gets loaded on
runtime and then, yeah, traces and blocks business
calls. So we have different actions. Right? So
we can block business calls, but we can
also trace them or lock them. It is
possible as well.
Okay. Then from my naive perspective, is it
okay to think of seccomp as, a firewall
for SIS calls? Yeah. Probably. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. The next stage there that I don't
went over was that Kubernetes
has support for the seccomp profiles, and they're
handled through annotations
on the pods
deck.
And the challenge with that
is
that they don't always exist in all the
nodes. Is that correct?
Yeah. So
there there's a couple challenges. Like, the first
one there is that
it's, you know, annotations are are, like, an
unstructured bag of data. Right? So it's not
immediately clear. You're not gonna get, like, validation
on on your annotations like you would with,
you know, the open API schema of a
pod. So that's kind of the first thing.
But more in relation to what you were
saying,
so when you
create a pod with this annotation, let's say
it's pre one dot 19 before it's moved
to the actual security context.
If that pod gets scheduled to a node
that didn't have that seccomp profile,
then that would be an issue. Right? Because
it it couldn't apply it.
So you could say, you know, typically
well, actually, I mean, I guess it depends
on the organization. But typically, you'd either have
them on all nodes in your cluster or
you'd have a very specific workload. Maybe this
is even more likely because set comp isn't
super common to have enabled
on workloads.
You typically have, you know, a specific node
that you're, like, forcing scheduling to that has
a set comp profiles there. So so yeah.
Basically,
you know, the the pod is an abstraction
for scheduling,
but set comp doesn't really, like, fit into
that abstraction, unfortunately. Right? It's node specific.
And you see other things like, you know,
let's say you want to use, like, GPUs
or something like that, you know, that's on
a node. There's other times you have to
do this. But because this is built into
the container runtime,
you you basically shouldn't have to do that.
Right? It's not like it's not like specific
hardware. It needs to be, you know, like,
obviously, like a Linux node and that sort
of thing.
But we're we're kind of paying a price
right now that you shouldn't have to, at
least in our opinion, I think.
Okay.
I'm kinda following along. I think the best
way to tackle this
is let's play with it. I mean Right?
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we also have this
kind of hierarchy of when it comes to
annotations or passing data around with annotations. Right?
So this is, from my perspective, kind of
a little of a problem for making users
actually use the feature because they have to
specify
an exact annotation.
And then they can say, okay. Now this
profile applies to the pod, but they can
also say, okay. It's it's
slash container name, and then you can reference
your container name inside of the pod to
apply the second profile only to a to
a single container. So and and this fact
already makes it pretty complicated to use. And,
yeah, we can
solve that issue by having a dedicated field
in the sec security context of the container
and the pod. Yeah. If I think if
we jump over to the repo, we could
look at some examples. I think we have
some the pods with annotations and with the
security context. Probably helpful
to take a look there. The seccomp operator
repository. Right? Yep. In Kubernetesorg.
Yep. That was I think, Tasha already put
a link in here too. There we go.
Nice.
You can ignore this mindset right now. It's
just our our brain dump.
I'm not sure I want to ignore it.
It's
very colorful.
Later. Later. Okay. So
what do you want me to pop open
then? I think installation and usage might be
good.
It's the app there at the top. That
would make sense. Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. So, yeah, we have the our stream
there. And then here, we're first, it's looking
at installing the operator
itself,
and then it's looking at creating a profile.
So we talked about beforehand
that right now, you'd go and actually kind
of, like, put this these JSON files
in a specific path on
your node.
And so what we're showing here basically is
just putting those JSON files in a config
map. And what the operator is gonna do
is it's gonna see that because of the
annotation there that's, you know, set comp.security at
kubernetes.i0/
profile. So it's gonna say the operator is
saying, look at all config maps with this
annotation on it,
and then it's gonna take all of those
profiles in line there and just put them
in a directory
on all of your nodes. Right? So it's
a daemon set. This operator is running on
every node. So each one of those processes
will go and actually put that on the
node.
And if you scroll down, then we'll show
usage of it,
which this usage obviously is not specific to
just seccomp operator. You could manually put these
in there and then do it, but you'll
see
the top one here
is
with one dot 19 where we have the
security context there and set comp profiles and
actually actual field there. And then you'll see
before one dot 19 below that,
you have that annotation,
you know, which is a little more cumbersome.
Right? You're not gonna get that validation and
that sort of thing.
So, yeah, that's a general idea. And as
as Sasha also mentioned, you know, a security
context, you can have it at the pod
level, and then you can also have it
more granularly at the container level. Can just
like any other thing, the security context, the
container level, the more granular one is gonna
override
the the top one. But if you're doing
that with the the annotations here, they're, like,
at the same level but overriding each other.
So it can be a little bit confusing
as well. Here, they're both being applied at
the pod level, though.
Alright. Got it.
So
I guess I could just run through these
steps on my cluster. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Sounds good to It's be nice
and easy. It's gonna work. And then
that's it.
So
I am running
on a Mac.
And
I still still don't know how to look
at tabs. There we go.
So that means that I have
it's several version of one sixteen. So if
I'm working with the Docker for Mac Kubernetes,
that means I need to use the annotation
based approach. Right?
Yes. You would you would need to if
you're using one dot 16 Kubernetes.
Perfect.
Well, let's install
this operator.
And I appreciate that there's a QPC channel
apply and not create.
And this is going to put stuff, I'm
assuming, in my cube system namespace?
No. We use it. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. And so you'll just see one
pod running here, right, because it's a a
single node
cluster you have here, presumably.
So it's a daemon set, so just one
will be running here.
One thing you could also do is
if you well, I guess you can see
it right there. The other things are created.
So
you can see that we have a config
map, which is for the seccomp pro the
seccomp operator itself. So, you know, as you
would want
with something that is gonna manage your seccomp
for you, we apply seccomp to it as
well. So that's what that config map is
for. Then you'll also see the default profiles
there,
which is just a collection
of profiles that would be,
we think, universally useful, especially right now when
people are just kinda getting their feet wet
with set comp.
There's some things to try out.
So yeah.
Alright. So I guess I could just pop
this open there and take a look at
it. Right? Yeah. Go for it. And you're
gonna be able to tell me what is
actually going on here. Yeah. We're gonna describe
every Sense call to you and exactly what
happens in the current model.
Well, here's a random pop quiz for you.
How many Sense calls are there?
What is it? 200? So is there 300
yet? I don't think so. There's 200 something.
Yeah. 200 something. Okay. So very matter then.
The seccomp operator shifts with his own seccomp
profile.
Right.
Yeah. And and, Sasha,
I mean, you or you or I could
go through how we actually there there is
some, like the net container, I think, is
kind of interesting how this gets applied. So
we might wanna look at actually you know,
there's kind of like a chicken and egg
thing. Right? Are you using how can the
seccomp operator, like, do the things it needs
to do
with the seccomp profile if it doesn't exist
yet to put the seccomp profile there? You
know, like, there there's a chicken egg thing
we can go through
in a little bit. But,
Sasha, do you wanna give kind of, like,
a rundown of what this profile has here
just like the different sections of the the
JSON here? Yeah. First of all, we have
our default action. So we just want to
throw an arrow in any case if anyone
any of the SIS calls which are allowed.
So this is the list down there. Any
other Syscalls should be forbidden.
And then we have our architecture. So we
don't have support for something like MIPS or
s three ninety or something like this. So
we just support x x x eight
architectures for now. And then you have a,
yeah, a list of SIS calls which are
allowed. And if you go a little bit
more down, can you go down to the
list? And there should be also an action
related to those SIS calls. Yes. So it's
the action allow.
And and those SYS calls are allowed. We
could also do it the other way around.
Right? So we could allow all SYS calls
and and deny some of them. But, yeah,
if there's a new SYS call coming into
a system, then we probably would allow it.
So it's not not the intention, not the
right security approach from my from our perspective
here.
And now we have a little list of
SYS calls, and some of them are necessary
to actually spawn the process. For example, if
you look at execve,
if we wouldn't
be allowed to run execve,
then we wouldn't be allowed to actually spawn
any process.
So run c or the underlying container runtime
wouldn't be
allowed to actually execute
the workload process.
So this is something we have to
really keep keep in mind. And there's also
something like uname down below, probably. Let me
it's just a rough guess. Yeah. There's uname.
And this is something which is required, for
example, for the Go runtime. So we wrote
a Go application,
and when we start this Go application, then
it does something like a u name to
look up some,
yeah, resources on which system we are running
on and stuff like that. So the runtime
has a little garbage collector
running in in the background, and it's necessary
to run the uname. If we, for example,
would deploy something like a c binary,
which is statically linked, then we probably would
not need uname at all, or we wouldn't
need to use calls like read or something
like this.
And
it's what it wasn't that easy to craft
the profile,
but we kinda recorded the SIS calls. And
even after recording the SIS calls, we just
saw that, okay, there are some SIS calls
missing.
And
this also kinda influences how we develop the
application. Right? So if we want to add
now new features which need new SIS calls,
then we indirectly have to adapt this the
second profile as well. And this can be
kinda
pain,
but
yeah. I mean, it's really a security driven
development approach, and I really really appreciate that.
Yeah. So, Rasha, I think you pointed out
something really important there about some of these
syscalls are, like, kind of unrelated to the
actual process that's eventually getting run. Right? Some
of them are specific to it running in
a container runtime,
etcetera,
which I think really emphasizes something we were
talking about before we started the stream about
wanting to be able to record the profiles
using the set comp operator.
Because if you were just, you know, looking
at this binary by itself,
depending on, you know, how you are running
it on your machine, you may not need
all of these different calls here or you
may need some that aren't present here, etcetera.
So,
you know, developing one
for the specific context you're running in
can be
a bit challenging,
which also gets introduced, right, if you want
to for instance, I I work on another
open source project for, like, my day job,
and
we we did a stream a while back
of crafting a set comp profile for it.
It's a little bit difficult to kind of,
like, ship a set comp profile with your
thing that's gonna be, like, generic. Right?
Because you don't know the context that people
are gonna be running
your your application in. You don't know the
underlying container runtime. You don't know a variety
of different things. You don't even know if
they're running it in Kubernetes perhaps.
So shipping a seccomp profile alongside of it
is difficult. But we think that just as,
you know,
you install
let's say, you know, like a service mesh
that has, like, security contacts on some of
the pods that are running, we think you
should be able to ship a seccomp profile
with that, and that should be able to
work.
And, you know, if if for some reason
it just absolutely cannot, then we should have
an easy out for that. Right?
So that's another area where we'd like to
make this a a more seamless process.
Okay. Right. It's it's just it's starting to
click. I'm getting there. So I think the
the first question I kind of got is
we've just deployed this operator now. What is
the
what is the process when I get this
wrong? Like, say, go and run a container
a pod here,
which has a profile and is trying to
execute as this pod doesn't exist. What kind
of errors, what logs am I getting back?
Is there something to help me understand what's
going on?
Yeah. So
the first thing during development of such a
profile could be to put the
action not to
arrow,
but to
its section. It's a it's a convection lock.
Right? Mhmm. And which locks the
error messages into the audit lock. And
the audit lock is something so it's audit
d, and audit d is not available on
every system we have to admit. And it's
also configured different differently on on systems.
But
for many default distributions like Ubuntu, for example,
then they would did that would result in
logging the action. And this is call this
is call number you have to look up.
This is call name then if you just
get a number.
Alright. I've got an idea. So
before I go through my weird idea, let's
pop open the other config map. Right? So
we got the default one.
So the idea behind this default one then,
and I'll just put words in your mouth
and you can correct me, is that this
should allow most processes to run without so
I guess it's it's blocking
the more extreme or dangerous this calls. Is
that it's
is that what it does?
I mean, this this profile and we wanted
to provide some default profiles for some common
applications.
And, for example,
this is for NGINX,
I think so. We only have one for
NGINX right now.
Oh, okay. I think I misunderstood that. I
thought this was, like, a default profile that
would, like, just block really dangerous syscalls and
let everything else do.
Oh, no. No. No. Most container runtimes already
ship their default profile.
But
on the other hand, we have to say
that the default profile in Kubernetes is unconfined,
so it's not applying seccomp at all.
But it's the profile called runtime slash default
or the duplicated profile is docker slash default.
Yeah. That that's a really good point. So,
like, right now, without the set comp operator
at all, you can use the underlying container
runtime default profile, which does exactly what you're
talking about, David, that it blocks super dangerous
things.
Honestly, like, it, you know, it that is
enhanced security. It doesn't really go a super
long way for for preventing things
because, right, it it doesn't want to
break your your functionality. Right? But that is
definitely the first step. I'm glad you pointed
out. That's definitely the first step to using
set comp just, you know, using the runtime
default profile. And if you're seeing issues, then
you probably have a fairly privileged workload that
you're trying to run there.
Alright.
I'm curious.
What happens if I don't allow the access
to this call?
It it depends. It depends on the application.
Right? So so this is another good point.
So
when recording this calls, it's not like when
you start a process that it just makes,
like, every syscall ever. You know, if it
especially if it's a long running process like
a like an operator. So the seccomp operator
is a great example of this.
You know, depending on input it receives, it
might make different syscalls. So you can't just,
you know, like, execute and be like, alright.
I know everything that's running. You technically should,
you know, have to go through, like, every
path to be, like, totally sure
to to know
not literally every path. But, you know, basically,
the idea is that you need to have
some real world use of it to be
able to understand what what calls it would
make, which is a great case for recording,
right, because you can just monitor something in
its normal operations and and see what happens
there.
Alright.
Awesome.
I'm feeling brave now.
But,
for example, exit is pretty interesting because it
would mean that the process is not allowed
to terminate itself.
That's what I was wondering. Like, what if
it what's the what if it's finished?
Yeah. Yeah. And it this could also this
could result in that the process just hangs
around.
I mean Wouldn't if it tried to make
a sit well, it depends I guess it
depends on what your policy is. But if
it's,
you know, an error policy, I believe that
the process is gonna get killed. So maybe
you're, like, effectively exiting there anyway. Like, maybe
we should just remove the exit call from
from all set comp profiles and then just
have it killed when it makes it.
But that that's a funny one to look
at for sure. Yeah. So if the default
action is to audit and an application wants
to exit, is it it's just gonna live
forever.
No. No. It would it would be if
the default action was to audit, it would
log, then the exit call is made and
allow it to actually exit. So it's not
yeah. It doesn't, like, it doesn't prohibit it
from happening.
Okay.
Cool. There we go.
Let's deploy NGINX then. Is that the is
that the next step here?
Yeah. Alright. So if I just do this
the really hacky way and then we edit
it,
We can add the profile. Or is there
something on the documentation here that's gonna make
this
okay.
We'll do it this way. I'll follow the
documentation,
and then it could says it.
So Internet with
that's not
Oh, the namespace
have to be has to be changed, I
think so. Also, the config with name.
Oh, so this is the one nineteen syntax,
actually. So what we're saying is I can't
use that, and I I I need to
use this one.
So I can just copy the annotation.
So local host, I'm assuming the space operator
is the operator. My namespace is going to
be,
like, operator
and
default
profiles
NGINX.
It's NGINX one nineteen, the other one.
So let so if I wanted to get
that, that's just the details from
that I just described
on tag map.
Default.
Alright.
Just
trying to make sure that I know how
that is built up. So this is the
key here.
The namespace of the default profiles is coming
from the names. That's local host operator
namespace
Yeah. Contact map name, and then the key
within the contact map. Yeah.
So the reason for that long path was
to not being able to override the second
profiles from a different namespace if I don't
have access to it
and things like that to have a security
from yeah.
As
the parsing is the security pattern here.
Yeah. And you can also as we'll see
later on, you can run the operator itself
in a single namespace.
Basically, only watching for config maps in a
namespace. So you could say, like, all of
my config maps will always be in the
set comp operator namespace, and I don't want
people with access to other namespaces and the
ability to create config maps. Go to do
that.
That could become less relevant as one of
the things we're exploring right now is creating
a set comp CRD
where you have a specific type that you
could grant our back on. So there's kind
of like a trade off, right, because
using a config map is something people are
already familiar with and know how to structure.
But you have unstructured data in there now.
Right? It's just like a bag of JSON
that that's not getting validated on creation.
And you can't apply our back specifically for
you know, you could use OPA or something
to write policies, but
you can apply our back to say, like,
you can't create set comp config maps. Right?
You can only say, you can't create config
maps or something like that, which, obviously, those
are used for many different things. You may
not want to do that.
Is there a plan to introduce a CID
in future versions?
Yeah. There's actually a PR open right now,
which I definitely wanna give the person a
shout out. So, Sasha, I didn't remember their
name.
If you want to drop it. Colleen. Yeah.
Colleen. So she's been working on that, and
and there's a PR open on the repo.
Folks wanna kinda, like, weigh in on that.
It's it's a fairly straightforward implementation,
right, because there's already a a defined, like,
API for a seccomp profile. So it's kind
of just, like, adding that in. But there
are a couple of, you know, like, decisions
about, you know, how we want that structured,
if you wanted to be able to put
multiple in one CRD or, you know, etcetera.
So definitely, people are welcome to weigh in
on that.
Awesome. I'm looking forward to playing with that.
So
what was I doing? We were gonna apply
this into the next platform. There we go.
That's my problem with these streams. Was that
I just have too many random thoughts in
my head, and I just digress far too
much from what I'm actually supposed to be
doing.
That's how you end up talking about interesting
stuff, though. Right?
I I hope so.
I certainly find that interesting. That's for sure.
It's definitely more fun for the people on
the stream.
Cool. I'm glad. I'm glad. So
we have a test part now
that is running with the
engine x profile based on the annotation.
Let's just Nice. Let me just check then.
Right? So I I can do a port
forward
to our test pods and
just confirm that I actually have an index.
Like, that's to me, that's step one here.
So
Nice.
I'm gonna go in the database part.
Better wrong.
Let's see here.
Oh, this says Caulfield.
Is that what that is?
Potentially.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean So I I was gonna
exec into it to do something the Internet
wouldn't do, and already it's blocked me. So
Yeah. That that's a that's a good example
right there. I mean, like, you know, you
want to
restrict your images with things it doesn't need,
like, you know, you don't want someone to
be able to exec into it if they
don't need to.
But here, that adds another layer. Let's say
you wanna use the NGINX pod and you
don't want people to exec into it.
Apparently, your set comp profile will disallow you
from doing that here.
So what I'm gonna do is go add
that Cisco and just assume I know how
to do it, please. I know if I
get anything wrong,
yell at me. And we do have a
question if you're feeling brave as well. So
I'll pop that up just now. We'll like
you to edit on the conflict note. Cool.
The question is from
Go ahead.
The question is from Robert, and he's saying,
so could the operator log syscalls and app
made that prevent it from running by the
profile?
Yeah. So
the if you set the the default action
or the action on a stanza
to to log instead of, you know, like,
error allow,
then it is gonna log those out.
I think that that that we could make
that a little bit easier to consume. Like,
there there's ways to, right, get to that
log. Like, for instance,
in the
the example in the Kubernetes docs that we
added, I'm running, like, a kind cluster locally.
So I just literally tail the syslog on
my local machine, and I can see those
syscalls logged out there.
But,
you know, we could potentially make that easier
to consume or or, you know, you you
could already export those somewhere else and and
there's probably frequently people are.
But building something to the operator that would
do that
would definitely be interesting as well. We I
I don't think we want to, like,
shove too much into this operator. Right? Like,
it shouldn't be like your logging mechanism, for
instance. But if there's something around
making that easier to consume,
I definitely think so. One thing we could
do is,
you know, like, do some sort of, like,
a venting
on
a pod or something like that to say,
like, oh, this was killed for this reason.
Right? So there's it should already say if
we got the pod now, like, you know,
something happened. It might actually even say that
message there.
But, you know, if there's something we can
add to that to make it a little
more transparent, that'd be a a great idea
for sure.
Awesome.
Really good answer.
So while you're answering that question, I did
edit
our contact map, and I added that Cisco,
which
oh, and then I can't even remember the
name of it. There we go.
Get PGRP.
Which Cisco is that? I'll ask you on
the spot.
I have no idea, Sasha. Save me.
Let's just
see what It's it's related to users and
groups somehow, but I'm not exactly sure what
it does, but it's something like user or
group. So it looks like it's setting and
getting process groups.
Yeah. So it it gets a group ID.
So I've added that. Now I already have
a running pod. I'm assuming that would be
updated in real time. So will I have
to kill the pod and redeploy?
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So we can delete.
That's a text part.
Yeah. Oh, okay.
I expect another this call now to show
up. But Yeah. Me too. This
is the joy of of crafting the second
part of us. And like I said in
that tutorial,
we do it by just logging all of
them and then, like, adding them. Well, we
also give you the completed one so you
don't have to do it. But when I
was writing that, I was logging them all
and, you know, it's like, oh, this one
works now. Alright. What's the next one we
need to fix?
So it can be be confusing for sure.
Yeah. Well,
I just did the gross period to you
though, and of course, there's no way that's
just full.
Some
let's give that
now.
Okay. So Good. How many of these do
you think we're gonna have before I actually
get inside of this
this container?
Oh,
a few for sure.
There's no Cisco load here, though. It cannot
set terminal process.
Alright.
So let's assume in like, we're already understanding
why this is a bit painful. Now we
knew this was coming. So
why don't
because it it could be it could be
dozens. Right? There's no point in going through
these one by one.
Yeah. I mean, like, for for for this,
There may be a point in doing it
for your your production workload, but
you're right. There could be there could be
dozens. Right? Because it's gonna kill on the
first one.
You could also set it to log, right,
and potentially get all of those at once
Yeah. Seen. So Okay. That that's a really
good idea. So let's but I I'm curious
first.
Can we set the default runtime one first?
Can you tell me how to do that?
Then we'll come back and maybe change the
engine x one to do log instead of
error.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. Sure. Sasha, do you wanna
instruct that one? I don't we want to
change oh, okay. I thought we would like
to change to not to error, but to
log for the NGINX profile. And then we
could look into audit log. I'm not sure
if audit log is audit is configured on
your system, but I would expect so. So
we should already see some ZS calls coming
in from the workload.
So what I was curious was
what we're saying is if we don't wanna
use
the default ones that are provided, there is
the container runtime default. I was wondering if
I could apply that to 10 exec into
the container.
Then, yeah, this will work. Yeah. We can
try it out.
Yeah. So how do I'm assuming the annotation
is the same. Right? So Yes.
Yeah.
So what's It's
just runtimes runtime slash default.
Is that it? That's all I need to
get a default. Yes. Yeah.
Why is that not in every piece of
documentation for deploying pods ever?
Because because it's an annotation.
Maybe.
Maybe because no one knows what seccomp is,
who's using Kubernetes. I'm not sure. That's that's
probably a huge generalization, but
I know a lot of people are not
familiar with it. But anyway.
But this I sorry, Andy. Go. Go. Sure.
Yeah. The fun fact is that that we
actually running a different application. Right? So we're
running on top of Bash now and not
on top of NGINX. So
So then yeah. Yeah. That's what I was
really curious. That's what I wanted to do
with the default NGINX profile because I didn't
think I would get blocked from getting inside
the container. That was just a value add.
That was cool.
What I wanted to do is something dangerous.
Like, the attack vector that seccomp is helping
people with is if someone penetrates my application
and gets access to the container,
we wanna stop them doing things that this
application isn't supposed to do.
So now that I'm
in here, like, is there a way for
me to introspect that second profile? Is it
available in a container under slash prop slash
one? Like
No. I don't think so. The
con the underlying container runtime,
our case, probably run c and applied the
profile already. So it's not possible for the
process at all to inspect the profile now
because the process is not that privileged.
We also yeah. We don't have access to
to something like this, but what could So
what would it block me from doing?
Like, what what would be a bad Cisco?
I
mean, runtime default is not very constrained. Right?
Let me just double check. Yeah. I'm taking
a look at it right now.
See. Because I'm assuming it's right. If I
could run PS, I I would only see
one port out there anyway. I mean, I
guess,
I would be able to
can I I can send this call to
the kernel from here? Right? Is that possible?
Can I just send this as well?
You could try. Let's
see.
Significant syscalls.
Here, I can I'll drop this in the
chat too.
Yeah. I'll do that. Let's do that. I'm
curious. Do
we have something like NS enter
in
the binary NS enter, for example?
Yeah. I'm assuming we can maybe get some
tools. So You could use, like, set NS
or something like that. Probably Debian based or.
Yes.
Yes. Set n s or n s enter
should not work. This should be blocked probably
because it would allow modifying the namespace.
Oh, namespace. It's there. It's.
No. Is NS enter in path already?
That
sounds dangerous.
Run a program with different preference send. I
mean, that sounds like something I shouldn't be
able to do without a default one ten.
I don't think it's actually explicitly blocked,
though, from what I'm looking at.
So
Let's see.
Does it have
wait. Let's look at the ones there.
Well, that I'll just look at that title
then. So
we're looking for set NS and say it's
been to
Well, lately, Ubuntu.
I'll say that in essence is allowed by
by default, I think so.
Think so. A
profile I'm looking at. I look probably, I'm
looking at a different profile.
So right now, as an attacker, I'm in
quite a good position and even work to
default,
potentially in a good position of default run
type.
Yeah. It depends on what you're trying to
do. But like we're saying, it's it's pretty
permissive.
Okay.
Right. We'll we'll move on.
I'm
not sure what I can do here to
try and trigger that default set of profiles
with you. Can we see that profile?
I'm looking the one I just put in
the chat here
looks like the one for Docker.
So this has a list of all the
blocked ones.
I don't know if, like, clone may be
available.
That one is also part of the allowed
sys calls.
It is part of the allowed ones? Yeah.
It says block on the docker docs here.
Alright. It's interesting.
It also says I can't meant.
So in theory, if I ever just to,
like, do a look back, man, if I
can even remember the syntax for that. Yeah.
You can just
yeah. Something like this.
Either they
I'm
never gonna remember that design.
Which
profile were you looking at, Sasha?
I'm
looking into a containers common
Oh, okay.
Profile,
which is used by bot man in Cryo.
But it was originally
adopted by
from Docker, which is the JSON. Yeah.
Just the link.
This one.
Nice.
Okay. So that works.
Yes. But that that that that that says
pro blocking me there, I'm assuming?
That's just the permission levels of the user.
Right? That's so it's not actually even getting
to
making this code, I don't think.
Is that is that how you interpret that,
Sasha?
But
if you just leave those
arguments
away and just do something like mount one
to two or something like this, should probably
also not work. One,
Yes.
Yeah. It's blocking. Looks like that this is
blocking.
Okay. So we can test that, right, by
just
deleting our wonderful pods here,
removing that one line, and then see if
I can execute that. Yeah. I I don't
know what I'm trying to show to myself
here. I'm just
I'm just very curious. So I'd have to
remove the workload. Right?
So one.
Oh, two, one, one.
Yeah.
I think that's the same error. Alright.
Oh, well, there goes that plan.
So what we're gonna do now is we
are going to
change the NGINX profile to not get me
the error, and then it should allow me
to exec and and then we can understand
the default action stuff. So
I pop open this default profiles again.
And the default action is
this. Right? Mhmm. So if you just change
error note to log,
then when you encounter something, you know, it'll
do.
It'll just log it instead of killing the
process.
Alright. Just click that. Okay. And then I
can delete
and reapply.
Did I run get pods?
What about broken?
Yeah. Describe describe the pod and see what
the events look like there.
And I create some sales tour.
So is my profile
Yeah. I'm wondering. Does your profile exist?
I'm assuming that's what's the problem.
What do we have done here? So, yeah,
this is very explicit allow
or default action.
But where would I find the default actions
if I wanted to do if I wanted
to see what options I have available here?
I believe the only actions are
log,
error, no, and allow.
I'm fairly certain.
Let me make sure on that, though.
Yeah. Those are the actions
which are part of the runtime spec,
the OCI runtime spec.
I always break stuff.
Yeah. That's interesting. So did you apply the
updated
profile before you created this pod?
Yeah. Well, yeah, I'm Edison in Lane.
How does the operator handle changes to the
conflict map? Do I need to restart the
operator?
You shouldn't need to.
See if there will you, Kaye, describe the
config map? Because we we do event on
the config map, so you should be able
to see
if anything went wrong there.
Let's see.
So three minutes ago, that would suggest that
that was saved successfully.
Interesting. Why
don't I edit it again?
Yeah. And then also look at that pod
spec and make sure that it's the right
name.
For error null, we said it's a a
note
that I describe again.
Five nine four minutes with the a saved
seccomp profile.
What does that mean? Is it not picking
up the changes? It's just a weird Docker
for matching. We're gonna find the notes.
Yeah. Try try and
Oh, we just remove it. Oh, no.
Yeah. Try try and removing the profile, and
then let's see if we can
add it again.
Or you can just delete the config map
either way.
Yeah. Let's delete the config map rather than
doing that. So delete
the comp on config map.
Do you have a copy of it locally?
I just copied it. Yeah. Oh, cool. You
can have default profiles
right, and all.
And I'll remove all those generated for that.
The one I need there. Yeah. Make sure
the app label? Profile true.
You
shouldn't need the label, but you do need
that annotation there.
But, yeah, if you leave it, it probably
won't hurt. Yeah. Okay. So we've got this.
And our profile,
that was good to me. Let's change this
back to the log then.
K.
And we'll apply our default profile.
Nice.
So let's read this gray
for a second, by the way. Okay. Cool.
So now that we've got this as log,
what we're seeing is
and we can now redeploy
our engine x part,
and I may or may not be able
to exact into that.
Oh, that load definitely seems to be
Yeah. That's interesting.
Oh, let's
see.
Air training. That's interesting.
I haven't seen this.
Can we
Should we just touch Docker for Mac?
Is that where we where we move over
to our app at a straight up black
box? Maybe that's going to be a bit
easier.
We could give that a try.
Yeah. I'm just curious if Docker for Mac
maybe doesn't implement
the
the default action. I mean, is that possible?
You're saying it's an OCI specs thing, so
it really shouldn't be. Right?
Yeah. It shouldn't be an issue to change
it from error node to log. But,
yeah, we could try it on on your
Linux box if you want. There was something
that Sasha said earlier
where
it logs to audit d. Is that what
you Yeah.
But now what if that doesn't exist? Because
this is gonna be
a Linux cut VM. Like, I I'm not
sure if things like audit d would be
there.
I think it should still work.
I don't know. Correct me if I'm wrong,
Sasha.
I'm just I'm not swinging in.
I'm not completely sure about the included
bits into the logging mechanism.
I know it looks to warlock messages, and
it can also look to, yeah, to audit
d, but
I'm not sure.
Interesting.
Okay.
Yeah. Let's try it on the Linux box
and see what happens.
Yeah.
Alright.
So
if we close this one,
this is my end of XPN. But I
came prepared because I figured there might be
something that happened.
Docker from Mac. Although, I'm not that prepared
because I didn't install Cain.
So I
don't think that's gonna be available there.
Cube. Otherwise, I'll just take care of it.
Yeah. Okay. Let's just get the Kind off.
We
also have a question. So why don't I
leave that to YouTube when I did this?
So Bella is asking maybe a silly question.
There's also a saying there's safe space here.
Can this operator
be used on pod specific labels?
Not right now.
But we were thinking
oh, I it just depends on what pod
specific labels means. I would interpret it as
that we have something like
a filter mechanism
for those for the profiles to apply the
profiles to a pod.
Then we were considering that. But we have
no real
feature
how we could implement it. So one idea
would be to have something like mutating webhooks
that we have
that we could, yeah, reference
second profiles in a more easy way directly
from the workload so that the operator can
actually
modify
a pod to apply a workload automatically after
recording or something like this.
Yeah. The closest you could get to that
right now, I guess, is using a pod
security policy that enforces
Yep. Using it, which isn't going to actually
add it for you. Right? It's just gonna
say, like, oh, you can't,
you can't create this pod without the seccomp
annotation or or security context here.
Alright. Thank you for that question. If anyone
else has any more questions, feel free to
drop them in the chat. We will do
our best to well, I won't, but, you
know,
my wonderful guest here will do their best
to answer them. So I now have a
cane cluster. Is it by magic?
I I have no I don't have cane
CTL.
Thank you for being too confident.
See, you learn so much on this livestream.
Right? You learn how to install kubectl.
You learn how to set comp stuff. You're
gonna have to break everything.
I I am just on fire.
So
On
kind, it should definitely work
because we have end to end test running
in kind, which also checks for the audit
log, which also uses the audit log.
Okay. We're back to where we were. So
let's
edit it.
Not gonna have my auto complete now. That's
gonna drive me crazy.
Edit our config map
default profiles.
We're gonna change this to error node log.
Yeah.
We are going to
run
this part.
X dot yaml.
And we are using
the default profile, which we've now just modified.
And kind spun off for one eighteen, so
we're still gonna use an annotation instead of
the security project.
Sounds good.
That one's
won't be the same error?
Looks like you do. Well no. So this
is a new machine. It won't have the
image yet. Oh, gotcha.
Yeah. Yeah. We'll connect the image. It's gonna
be okay.
I'm so impatient.
Like,
what is next?
Although, maybe it's not gonna kill the image
because I would expect that to come now,
which means maybe there is an error.
Maybe
Yeah. Let's see. Yeah. I'm just gonna push
it. Code. Oh, no. That's good.
Okay. So now it's running.
Nice. So
with it with this profile, what was failing
with Docker for Mac was my ability to
then exec inside of this container.
Yeah.
There's no works, but we don't care about
that. What we actually wanna care about is
where did this log?
Or Yeah.
Now we have to exit the node.
So
yes. That's right. We're in. I'm not on
the action. Yeah.
So
we can jump and say it.
K.
Yeah. Now we can look into Warlock
AuditD, probably.
It's not there
because I think time doesn't ship all the
d.
You should be able to actually, just on
the machine itself,
they should flow through to the syslog. Right?
So you could probably tail the syslog. So
if you just do, like, tail
dash
let's see.
And if you could grep for
test pod. Yeah. Yeah. That's it.
Nice. That's the audit log. Yeah.
So there you get the syscall. You've got
+1 09271113489.
So these are all ones.
So so since we have that allow block,
the you know, that's that whatever block is
gonna take precedent of the default action. Right?
So these are all ones that would be
blocked in Arano. So, you know, if we
wanna switch it back to Arano, we need
to add all of these different
syscalls there.
And you can run something like a new
syscall and then your this is call number,
and then you get the name for it.
Yeah.
Ah.
Okay. If it exists.
I
actually Well, don't know what he used this
call is.
What what is that?
Not sure which one. I actually haven't used
it before either.
Typically, I just use one of those websites,
you know, that has, like, the searchable thing.
It's probably part of the auto d package.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's what I got from here. So
I see,
yeah, audit d there. So Nice.
Now it should be available.
Yeah. I'm learning. I'm learning. Yeah. Really? Yeah.
I just pick random numbers.
Yeah. I'm
so easily impressed. Okay. That's really cool too.
So
how how do I send this as can
I just send a random Cisco for the
kernel? Is there, like, a way of debugging
that?
Yeah.
Alright. We'll pass on that.
I'll stop trying to stop running, like, random
brain
thoughts actually. Yeah. So
But for example, you could also do something
like if you have a running or a
binary application, something like okay.
S trace, for example, is pretty easy to
use. So if we run something like S
trace minus c and then l s,
s trace is not available. Yeah.
We can fix that. Yeah. I know that
I know that package then. S
trace minus c and then l s, for
example, should give us an idea about which
SYS calls are now required to run this.
And if we now run something like s
trace minus c l s slash,
then there should be yeah. Then we have
a different list of SYS calls because it's
higher privileged. Interesting. Right?
So it really depends on the application and
what we want to do.
And allowing something like
exec ing into a container workload is probably
good if you think about debugging an application,
but
we also have to reconsider then that we
then allow
yeah.
We have to allow additional resources to actually
do something with with the bash, for example.
Right.
So
does that not make generating
I'm not gonna say easy, but, you know,
if I can just do s traced s
c l s, and then assuming I just
do, like Yeah.
Print
by
how did that not work?
I mean and
that should work. I know it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. We had some discussions last week about
how we could record those profiles, and the
idea was, yeah, we could some run something
like S Trace, but S Trace has a
has a performance implication.
And if we, for example, run it without
minus c, then we get all the details
which we don't need. So we also get
all the paths for
which got accessed during the loading of the
libraries and things like that.
And
there is some new feature on the Linux
kernel. I'm not sure if it's that new,
but it's called the second modifier.
And this is pretty interesting because we can
create some client server architecture we call in
between seconds. So we can have something like
a server,
which is monitoring the actual application, and the
server provides a file descriptor for clients.
So
which could be a different process, on our
case, probably the operator.
And this operator gets then all the ZIS
calls during the or due to the second
notifier feature.
And one idea would was to
yeah. How could we now bring this into
the operator?
And there are multiple ways. For example, there's
a different container runtime like c run, which
now propose something like a plug in mechanism
that we can
have something like a notifier plug in to
record to record the profiles.
And
but all of those topics are not really
standard. So we also have to say, okay.
We probably can't support it on every machine
because, yeah, not every Linux can also support
the second modifier, for example.
There are also some ideas about
to do the same, like like the s
trace thing. We could compile a little BPF
module into something like an OCI hook, and
this OCI hook will be trickled right before
the workload starts,
gets the process ID, and then starts the
recording, and then puts the recorded SIS calls
into a predefined
JSON blob.
Yeah. But this would also not work, for
example, with container d because container d does
not support OCI hooks yet. Or, for example,
it would also not work with Docker.
So
we are just evaluating,
and we are thinking about possible
solutions around it. But
it's not that easy. Right? So Yeah. It
this is really is is really high for
those profiles. If we want to have something
like s trace, what is also BPF trace,
for example, which can
where we can register
tracing points for this calls on the system,
but then we would record this this calls
on the whole system and would have to
look for our process so our container process.
I guess the the challenge there, though, is,
right, is that in order to use s
trace or BPF to extract syscalls from the
application, you have to run through every code
path. Right? Because, like, even just with that
really trivial l s example that you showed
me that the syscalls that were used between
one director and another were different. Like, so
if I were to profile or try to
create create profile for engine x and
someone just hadn't had a certain endpoint that
uses, like, a redirect syntax, then you'd never
know that syscall was there. Yeah. Is there
not I'm sure there isn't or maybe there
is. But, like, I'm assuming just analyzing the
ELF binary itself is the best way to
get that information.
Is that not possible?
Yeah. This could be possible as well.
I mean, if the binary is stripped, then
we don't have a chance to get to
this call back in.
So you said that at
the start of this kind of stream,
you've been working on a way to generate
profiles. Is that something you you wanna walk
us through?
Yeah. Yeah. I can show it I can
show it to you if you want.
Let me just share the screen here.
Well, you should see see it now. Right?
So I just played around a bit. So
yeah. I mean,
I have this OCI hook installed,
which is just a JSON which executes a
binary right before the container workload starts. And
I have to be run Podman as a
privileged user here because otherwise, the the hook
wouldn't be able to export through record the
SYS calls. So this is a real drawback.
We have to increase the
or decrease the security footprint by doing something
like recording those calls. So this could be
could be a problem in the future. But
what we would
have to do now is just to add
another annotation to the workload, which is this,
and that way, IO container strace this call.
And then we can specify an output file.
And,
for example, for other container runtimes like Cryo,
it would work in the same way. We
could also just add this annotation to the
Kubernetes workload and then record the profile into
a directory.
And if we now run something like let
me just change that. Yeah. We
run echo
high
without attaching a TTY and without doing anything
in bash,
then it should succeed.
Yeah. This succeed. And if we now look
into the profile,
then we can see that we have now
a generated profile here. So it has the
same default action for error and some just
calls in.
Also,
me just save that.
And now let's do something different. Now we
want to to attach a TTY and also
run echo high. I just
just override it, and then we
have a look into that.
Save it as my second profile.
And if we know this goes,
and we can see that we have, for
example, different set of SYS calls here,
which is pretty interesting.
Very cool.
And I guess
sorry, Nico. I mean, we can yeah. We
can we could also do something that's just
attached to the profile and run something like
l s or what what else could we
do. We could do something like r and
d and remove
or we could create a directory,
and we could remove it again.
But this works. And if we now Can
you click our minus nine one? Oh,
we
can try it afterwards. One second.
And we know it created a third profile.
It's just
with our second and our third.
We can see that we have, yeah, many
more. We have to execute batch, for example.
We have to fork a process. We also
have to get
our current directory, for example. Otherwise, we would
not be able to change into a directory.
And we also should have yeah. We have
on deal.
And we also have
MKDO, probably. Yes.
So how did you exit that container?
Control d?
Yes.
And because I don't see the exit Cisco.
A completely random observation, but it wasn't there.
I mean, mean, I'm not sure if it
triggers exit in the back, but let me
just check.
Yeah. The second and the fourth, probably.
Okay. For batch, we need all those SYS
calls down here
and exit.
Exit is part of both, probably.
No. It's not. It's exit group. It's not
exit group, but it's part of both. I'm
pretty sure that I if I run control
v, then it will do something like detaching
from the TTi and then doing something like
exit exit group or exit the process.
Okay. So here's a
random
thought.
Can you just run that against
NGINX?
Oh, yeah. Mean, how how how accurate would
that be to the default profile that is
shipping on the second popular end?
Yeah.
I can do that. So NGINX.
Okay. It was And I mean, I 19.
I'm curious now. Right? So you from what
you've been telling me so far, this dash
dash annotation on Podman is using something called
an OCI hook. Can you explain that that
to me? What what what does OCI hooks
enable?
Yeah. So the OCI
runtime specification
has a direct feature baked into, which is
called OCI hooks. And runtimes can support it
to, for example, run a pre start hook,
which
gets executed directly before the container workload starts.
And this hook is just can can can
be any binary,
and then we can pass our information down
to that hook like the output path of
our
yeah. For our profile.
And but not every container runtime supports it
for now because I'm not sure. I don't
think that container t supports it,
and this is going to be a problem
to bring a feature via an OCI hook
down to to all users.
Yeah. So now we have this NGINX still
running. I just can exit it again.
And if we look at NGINX
dot JSON, then it looks like this.
And we can also I just would like
to reformat it.
And we can also diff this one
with the one in the seccomp operator.
I mean, what I would expect to see
different here is that there's no accept call
because we never browse to it. So I
guess things like that would cause the profiles
to be different.
I
think we
I think I have to resort
this one. Yeah. There there you go. There's
no except. So Yeah. Because we never went
down that code path. We never actually made
a request to reset it. It's a very
cool tool. That's that's nice. I mean, that
would make this so so much easier for
people to I can just share that.
It's this one.
But it's also, say, on BPF hook.
Yeah.
Has to run with a higher set of
privileges. We have to need something like admin.
Yeah. So this is pretty high privileged
when it turns to security from the security
perspective.
And we also need the kernel headers
on disk,
which is also kind of strange, but we
have to compile a BPF module on the
fly right before executing the hook.
And, yeah, therefore, we would have a need
for for having the actual
kernel headers for the currently running kernel on
disk.
So
So is it possible then if say, I'm
using Kryo as a run time for Kubernetes
and just to enable that tracing on all
my applications for a week, two weeks, and
and collect profiles.
Yeah. This this would be this would be
possible, but I'm not sure if it's a
good idea to do that into in production.
Right? So I'm not completely sure about the
security implications we we introduced
with that hook.
So we we also have another question, which
think is is touching on a few things
that we've covered today. So Igor is saying,
it may be hard to debug a failing
application with a second profile active, which I
think we've kind of already confirmed because I
couldn't exec them to the container.
What are what are my options for
can I change a profile
and line actively, or do I always have
to restart the process to make a modification
to that? No.
I mean, we have to restart the process.
Right? And this is also some implication we
had. It's about a general architecture of Kubernetes.
Right? If you change an annotation,
then
it it restarts the profile. But for example,
if you change the content of the profile,
which is not directly referenced by the or
which is only referenced by text by the
annotation, then it won't have any influence on
the actual workload.
So yeah.
Yeah.
We thought about solving this somehow, but it's
probably not cool if the operator comes around
and restarts your workload because just the second
profile updated, something like this.
Not not that easy decision.
Yeah. Well, that that brings up another point.
I mean, a big thing right now is
if you actually delete a config map,
then it's not going to actually get cleaned
up out of the directory.
So that that profile still exists even if
you delete it. Delete the config map that
led to its creation.
And you may think, you know, initially, that's
not a good thing and, you know, maybe
it's not.
But what if you delete a config map
and there's a pod using that set comp
profile and then later on that pod gets
restarted?
It's just gonna fail, right, because it's not
gonna be able to access that set comp
profile. So right now, we're we're thinking about
actually, I muted there.
How we want to,
be able to clean those up.
And one way to do that is to,
you know, get a list of all the
pods and say, alright. I'm going to clean
this up if no pod is currently using
this seccomp profile.
So that case, you don't get, you know,
where, like, a pod gets evicted and then
can't restart.
Or you could do things like, you know,
keep a a global list, you know, somehow
of of what pods are are are there.
So just trying to do that without, you
know, huge performance implications.
But in general, like, pods and, you know,
getting pods with a certain annotation is not
a super big deal, especially, you know, we
don't anticipate that people are gonna gonna be
deleting set comp profiles, like, multiple times a
second or something like that.
So that's likely something we can do, but
it may also be something where we want
to be configurable depending on how folks wanna
interact with it.
Awesome. So
is there anything with the seccomp
operator that we haven't covered yet?
Is it what am I missing?
I think we've covered most of it in
its current state. We have, like and we've
mentioned a lot of a lot of ideas
for the future.
So if anyone's tuned in today and and
saying, you know, I I need this functionality,
like, definitely open an issue. Definitely show up
to our meetings. There's also the set comp
operator profile
or channel in Kubernetes Slack.
One big thing, which I don't think we
touched on yet or maybe I just forgot,
is we're thinking about right now renaming
this to the security operator.
The reason for that being is that you
can pretty easily extend this functionality to some
other things, namely the most obvious would be
AppArmor,
which is kind of similar to to set
comp,
and we'd like to be able to support
that. And I I think Sasha is actually
leading the charge for making AppArmor GA as
well in Kubernetes for an upcoming release, hopefully,
one dot 20.
And so as that happens, it'd be a
great time to also introduce AppArmor functionality into
the operator.
And then there's also some other things we
can do with security. So in general, set
comp is one the things we think is
valuable
and is underused because it's it's hard to
work with, and we'd like to extend that
to other things as well.
So, you know, that kind of opens up
the scope of the operator quite a bit.
But, hopefully, it becomes something that people can
kind of, like, trust on to help make
using security features of Kubernetes
a lot easier.
Awesome.
I guess the the next question after that
then is
what's next for this Stack On top here
besides the our commerce stuff? Is there anything
else coming coming soon?
Yeah. So we are working on the CRD,
which should which is based on the RCA
runtime specs.
The second profile specification, so it should be
give us some good opportunity to validate the
content early on.
And
then we are working on the recording, but
I'm I'm not sure if the recording makes
it into a feature anytime soon, or maybe
we are target we are trying to target
another release for this year. And yeah.
Let's see. At least as a proof of
concept, we could edit, and then we could
try to get some feedback from users.
Awesome. Well, I just wanna thank you both
for making seccomp understandable for me and for
making it easier for everyone with your hard
work. Like, honestly, I didn't expect seccomp being
something that I would kinda be able to
get a handle on in such a short
amount of time. And I think you've both
done a great job of kinda walking through
this. That's amazing. Thank you. Thank you. That
which means you're both now committed for helping
me understand the SEO Linux future date because
I have no idea how the hell that
works either.
Yeah. Well, that that's another area where, you
know, it brings some of that functionality to
the operator would be would be awesome. So
but thanks for having us on. It's been
super fun.
And outside of this episode, I love all
the stuff you're doing with the the other
folks you've had on as well. So appreciate
you making good good content to help people
learn and, you know, be aware of things
happening in the community.
Thank you very much. That's awesome. Feel happy
now. Well,
I will let you both get back to
your days.
If anyone has questions, you can reach out
to all of us on Twitter. All of
our handles are nicely on the screen. Of
course, there's comments on YouTube.
And thank you very much for watching, and
have a nice day all. Thank you. See
you. Bye bye. Cheers. Bye.